so we're about to run out of time which
is a good time to ask about the 10
Thousand-Year
clock
funny that's what I'm known for is the
humor okay uh can you explain what the
10,000 year clock is 10,000 year clock
is a physical clock of monumental scale
it's about 500 ft tall it's inside a
mountain in West Texas in a chamber
that's about 12 F feet in diameter and
500 feet tall 10,000 year clock is a
idea conceived by a brilliant guy named
Danny Hillis way back in the
80s um the idea is to build a clock as a
symbol for long-term thinking and you
can kind of just very conceptually think
of the 10,000 year clock as it it it you
know it ticks once a year um it Chimes
once you know every hundred years and
the cuckoo comes out once every thousand
years so it just sort of slows
everything down and um it's a completely
mechanical clock it is designed to last
10,000 years with no human intervention
so the material choices and everything
else um it's in a remote location both
to protect it but also so that visitors
have to kind of make a a
pilgrimage the idea is that over time
and this will take hundreds of years
but over time it will take on the patina
of age and then it will become a symbol
for long-term thinking that will
actually hopefully get humans to extend
their uh thinking Horizons and my view
that's really important as we have
become as a species as a civilization
more powerful you know we're really
affecting the planet now we're really
affecting each other we have weapons of
mass destruction
we have all kinds of things where we can
really hurt ourselves and the problems
we create can be so large you know the
the unintended consequences of some of
our actions like climate change putting
carbon in the atmosphere as a perfect
example that's an unintended consequence
of the Industrial
Revolution got a lot of benefits from it
but we've also got this side effect that
is very detrimental we need to be we
need to start training ourselves to
think longer term long-term thinking is
a giant lever you can literally solve
problems if you think long term that are
impossible to solve if you think
shortterm and we aren't really good at
thinking long term as you know it's not
really we're kind of you know five years
is a tough time frame for most uh
institutions to think
past um and we probably need to stretch
that to 10 years and 15 years and 20
years and 25 years and we' do a better
job for our children or our
grandchildren if we could stretch those
thinking Horizons and so the clock is in
a way it's an art project um it's a
symbol um and it if it ever has any
power to influence people to think
longer term that won't happen for
hundreds of years but we have to you
know we're going to build it now and let
it acre the patina of age do you think
humans will be here when the clock runs
out here on Earth I think
so but you know the United States won't
exist whole civilization rise and 10,000
years is so
long like no nation state has ever
survived for anywhere close to 10,000
years and the increasing rate of
progress makes that even even less
likely so do I think humans will be here
yes what you know how will we have
changed ourselves and what will we be
and so on so on I I don't know but I
think we'll be
here